on peut pas dire faites plusu vert et
puis on va aller chercher des poulets
Ukrainiens qui sont poussés en dans des
bâtiments qui sont plus acceptables chez
nous du sucre ukrainien qui pousse à
partir de betterave OGM traité au
Roundup et en Robé de Néo qu'on n' pas
le droit ou plus le droit de faire chez
nous depuis bien longtemps voilà à un
moment donné on demande de la cohérence
et de la visibilité parce que
l'agriculture c'est pas de l'industrie
lourde mais ça ça s apparente on
investit sur des temps longs et on a
besoin de visibilité sur des temps longs
donc aujourd'hui on est dans le dans le
Vexin moi je produis des céréales des
betteraves et du lin à fibre là on est
en plein hiver
donc bah les cultures en place il reste
plus que les céréales donc le blé mais
par contre vous avez des terres qui sont
préparées pour accueillir les premières
cultures de printemps aujourd'hui cette
agriculture là elle est elle est
forcément en péril c'est pour ça qu'on
est dans la rue aujourd'hui c'est pour
dire c'est important de soutenir notre
agriculture et pas celle qui vient
d'ailleurs alors on a plusieurs
problématiques qui s'accumulent depuis
quelques années sur nos exploitations la
problématique numéro une c'est l'écart
de moyen de production entre nous et nos
voisins européens et entre nous
Européens et les importations qui
viennent des pays extérieurs et c'est de
là que découlent les les les les
principales complications de l'ensemble
des agriculteurs queles que soient les
production c'estàdire que on a demandé
aux agriculteurs depuis des années de
monter en gamme de faire plus vert de
faire plus bio de faire plus plus de ha
plus de choses comme ça sauf qu'en
parallèle euh bah le consommateur ne
répond pas c'estàd que le consommateur a
besoin du moins cher et donc le
politique pour pas pour contenter le
consommateur a préférer importer de la
marchandise qui est complètement
déconnectée en terme de norme et ce qui
nous met dans une une situation
compliquée où nos marchandises plutôt
milieu de gamme haut de gamme ne se vens
pas chez nous et ont tendance à être
exporté et en contrepartie les
marchandises d'entrée de gamme sont
importés d'Amérique du Sud duukraine et
cetera et cetera là comme machine bah il
y a surtout des tracteurs mais il y a
ici vous avez un strip Teal ça sert à
implanter du maïs en direct sans
travailler l'intégralité des sols là-bas
vous avez un semoir de semidirect qui
sert à implanter des céréales derrière
directement derrière betterave sans
travailler le sol voilà donc ça c'est un
peu révélateur du fait que
bah tout ça c'est des investissements
qui ont été faites pour faire évoluer
les pratiques pour euh s'orienter vers
vers ce que on nous demandait de faire
donc plus de couvert moins de travail du
sol et cetera tout le matériel qu'on a
autour de nous ça vaut cher nous quand
on investit c'est sur des pas de temps
de de 10 15 20 ans et donc le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les politiques
s'amusent à changer les règles du jeu
tous les 4 matins et donc c'est pas
possible nous en tant que chef
d'entreprise on peut pas euh être en
permanence à la merci de décisions
politiques qui viennent impacter
complètement notre revenue là vous avez
plusieurs tracteurs vous avez la
moissonneuse de l'autre côté en gros sur
une
exploitation de de 200 hactares chez
nous il faut pour tourner dans une année
pour pour schématiser l'extrême 20000 l
de gasoil donc jusque là c'était du GNR
qui était détaxé c'est le gasoil non
routier et demain ben on nous remet une
taxe et ben forcément cette taxe on va
la subir de plein FO pourquoi parce que
des tracteurs il en existe que des
thermiques donc on est obligé de payer
la
taxe donc tous les documents qui sont
liés à à l'entrée des fertilisants après
il y a tous les papiers de traçabilité
bon attention hein c'est que la partie
papier mais aujourd'hui on est beaucoup
en dématérialisation on passe notre
temps aussi sur l'ordinateur donc on a
des normes qui découlent directement des
des textes européens mais alors après
comme on est français on en rajoute
encore on surnorme on surtranspose donc
ça ça c'est une norme française et puis
comme c'est pas encore assez ça arrive
que sur certains schémas départementaux
on en rajoute au niveau des régions et
des département mais aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il y a un réchauffement climatique
qui va menacer les agriculteurs en
première ligne on a besoin de mettre
quand même des normes sur l'agriculture
pour contrôler les émissions pour
contrôler les pollutions et cetera le
grand argument du moment c'est ah oui
mais le réchauffement climatique le
verdissement et cetera et cetera ok sauf
que quelle est l'alternative on va
mettre une norme écologique
supplémentaire sur nos agriculteurs
français on va aller chercher la
marchandise ailleurs si vous arrêtez de
de d'arroser par exemple des haricot
chez nous parce que vous dites bah crise
allez on arrête les haricots les
haricots ils vont venir du Kenya est-ce
que c'est
logique donc ça c'est les champs de la
ferme ou on arrive au bout des champs de
la
ferme donc là on est parti sur le point
de blocage de la 16 à beauovvet
puisqu'il y a un regroupement
d'agriculteurs pour bah pour faire
entendre notre colère qui a pas été
entendu jusque là donc là on arrive sur
le le blocage de la 16ise où nos
collègues ont sont rentrés et ont bloqué
l'autoroute on espère que ça va
permettre une écoute plus
attentive ça va j'ène les
journalistes qu'il faut qu'on demande
c'est de la cohérence et la cohérence
c'est quoi c'est la même règle pour tous
en Europe ça c'est la base et pour ce
qui rentre chez nous un peu de contrôle
et un peu de normes aussi des normes pas
que chez nous desormes normes un peu sur
ce qui rentre depuis 2 ans on est
importateur net de sucre en Europe faut
quand même avoir ça en tête on narrive
même plus à produire notre sucre c'est
quand même dingue et il va être produit
où en Ukraine ou alors au Brésil sur des
terrains qui sont déforestés qu'est-ce
qui est le mieux à moment donné il va
falloir comprendre que les contraintes
écologiques ici et ben ça fait des
catastrophes écologiques à l'utre bout
du
monde c'est un mouvement national parce
que les contraintes sont nationales et
on n' pas prévu d'arrêter on s'arrêtera
quand on aura des réponses précises et
concrètes donc vous voyez on n pas trop
mal installé bon bah tant qu'on a pas
des réponses précises et concrète et et
et pas des des
euros qui nous sont balancés comme ça
avec 8000 formulaires et cetera on veut
des réponses concrètes des avancées
concrètes